foreign
[Music]
to those watching on YouTube I do feel a
little bit bad that the first couple of
speedrun games they were lackluster so I
I listened through the videos and they
were not my best speedrun videos
I know nobody holds that against you
because I can't control how our
opponents play but I just wanted to
mention that I think I think we're gonna
have some great games in the speedrun
it's just it just takes a little bit of
time until we reach a level where the
games get competitive enough so I
apologize if the games thus far have
been a little bit one-sided it's just
part of of ascending the lower levels
and hopefully it's been tolerable okay
on we go to the next game let's roll the
cameras here we go
and I'm going to actually grab a
notebook we are black
my efficient
official the king's Indian I would not
be able to sleep peacefully at night if
I didn't recommend the king's Indian as
my sort of main Legacy Bishop G5
trompowski this is the trumpowski named
after Brazilian
uh I think he was an international
Master Octavio trumpovsky
and uh as most of you should know
the there's a couple of moves in this
position that black can play there's a
misconception that 94 is the only
feasible move that's totally untrue
black actually has many ways to equalize
their Z6 even G6 is quite reasonable D5
is a good move that's underrated even C5
can be played but the move that I have
always played is in fact Knight to E4
this is the principled line and this is
the line that you should play if you
really want to take it to uh to take it
to your opponents
um and after the game I'll give you a
brief overview of some of the other
lines okay 94. and of course at a lower
level a move like this is is very likely
to cause immediate consternation H4
now full disclosure I am not you know
too familiar with the current
theoretical recommendation H4 is I think
called the Hodgson variation
it's an incredibly uh double-edged move
and if you're sort of new to chess and
you're watching this you might feel very
disoriented right now like what's going
on I'm I'm making the same move with two
pieces White's responding by pushing a
corner Pawn the idea of H4 is actually
very easy to understand it's not a
mysterious move well first of all
White's defending the bishop right and
the thing is if black takes the bishop
on G5
white recaptures with the H fund and
what has been the effect of that trade
well let's think about it visualize the
position in your mind well as a result
of HD hd5 two things happen both of
which favor white the first
is that the H file has opened up and
white stands to benefit from that
because black is the one with the pawn
on H7 which of course restricts the Rook
but a company that is the fact that the
G5 Pawn is deep freezing blacks kingside
pawns we talked about the Deep Freeze in
my end game videos that's a situation
where one Pawn is restricting a whole
set of Pawns on a side of the board and
you can conceptualize this in the same
way that pawn on G5 is making it very
hard for black to eradicate the weakness
of the H7 Pawn because after Knight G5
hd5 if black were to ever play H6 then
white could take on H6 and if black
recaptures then Black's entire King side
has been seriously damaged so as far as
I know Knight takes Bishop is not the
best move here black has a bunch of
stuff that they can do
um and I think that we're actually going
to play it in a very simple way
the move that I know cannot be bad
it's D5 just play D7 D5 occupy the
center with a pawn and toss the ball
right back into white score
of course the the drawback of the move
H4
apart from the fact that it doesn't
develop a piece is that it uh it commits
it commits white to a life of
uncertainty with respect to their King
right white is now unlikely to be able
to Castle kingside because the king side
has been seriously damaged Castle in
Queen side in such positions is always
incredibly risky especially with the
night sitting on e4 like this
um and staying in the center similarly
is also uh quite dubious so H4 is is an
incredibly committed move Knight D2 our
opponent knows uh knows his theory
Knight D2 okay well
again we have multiple ways I think to
respond to this
um but we're gonna keep it incredibly
simple I don't want to take on G5 I
think that plays right into White's
hands and that's kind of what white
wants to see although after Knight G5
hd5 we can continue striking at the
center with a move like C5
but the move that I I kind of like I
played this against Levy in our casual
Blitz game in Canada and I lost uh but I
didn't lose because of this move I lost
because I blundered a little bit later
I think we can play it very simple just
drop our Knight back either to F6 or
even to D6 and just get a symmetrical
type of position that resembles a
Queen's Gambit declined
so Knight D6 Knight F6 I really really
like
let's just go back to F6
let's just go back to F6
and you might say well
we've made we've moved one minor piece
and it's been the same minor piece for
three moves in what Earth is that
justifiable
well remember that the center is still
quite closed so the effect of moving the
same piece more than once has been
diminished the consequences aren't as
easily felt and also remember what has
white done with these extra Tempe well
White's played the move H4 which is a
significantly weakening move
so it's not like white has fully
squeezed the you know the juices out of
the fact that we have moved the same
piece E3
well the point of going to and fro with
the Knight is that we have induced the
move H4 you can think of it that way we
have provoked a serious weakness on the
king side now we move our Knight back
and we develop along uh in conventional
terms conventional means okay H4 uh E3
so
the funny thing is is like we've been
consider move ordered into a type of
structure that we're not going to get
uh many times because we're gonna play
The King's Indian in response to D4 in
the speed run but nonetheless it's good
to know how to handle positions uh with
pawns on D4 and D5 like you get in the
Queen's gamma decline many ways that
black can handle this type of position
but if you want to play in principled
fashion then you can almost consider
this a reverse Queen's Gambit declined
right and what does that mean a reverse
Queen's Gambit well in the Queen's gamut
white usually plays c2c4 so here we can
do exactly the same thing but from the
opposite side from the black side and we
can prepare the move C5 but
after a C5 we have to be careful about D
takes C5 and because white is already
developed as Knight after C5 dc5 E6
white can then solidify the C5 Pawn with
a move before and I don't really see a
compelling reason that we should deal
with any of that I think that we should
start with the solid movie six and then
follow up with C5 on the next move and
what is the purpose of pushing the pawn
up to see if I was just to contest the
center right it's just to occupy more of
the center and put pressure on White's
Center Pawn right you shouldn't
overthink the move C5 it's just normal
stuff in such a position are we worried
about blocking in our Bishop yes that is
a drawback of the movie six so you might
say well shouldn't we have gone Bishop
F5 first I'll talk about that a little
bit more after the game as it turns out
the bishop on F5 can be quite vulnerable
in such positions and again because the
center is closed not every piece needs
to be Distributing the covered vaccine
we can always find Kettle the light
squared Bishop
you know the fact that it's temporarily
blocked by one of our pawns is really
not an issue 92. let's go C5
let's go C5
we can also at some point throw in the
move H6 to force this bishop to commit
uh but but there's no there's no
immediate compelling rush to do it this
pin is not dangerous remember that an
easy way to determine whether a pin is
dangerous is to detect first and
foremost whether the pinned piece is
protected by a pawn and if it is the PIN
is likely to be uh innocuous as it is
here okay so we're playing C5 hopefully
our moves thus far are making sense it
bothers me a little bit that the game
has proceeded along rather
unconventional means so it could be a
little bit hard to understand some of my
moves but just just bear with me and
I'll talk more after the game do you
take C5 okay well obviously we should
take back with the bishop
which is precisely why we started with
E6 in the first place and our opponent
has arranged his or her Knights rather
strangely on E2 and D2 of course this is
a rather passive way of developing
but A3 is a good move probably
white is preparing B4
okay so a lot of people here would have
the automatic reaction of playing A5
but remember that not every idea should
always be prevented right B4 is not a
threat it's just our opponent's idea and
there's nothing wrong with the move A5
you can prevent before that's decently
that's a decent idea but but you should
ask yourself is before all that
dangerous right what is the effect that
B4 have on the position well it chases
our Bishop away from C5 but our Bishop
is more than happy to be chased away
from C5 it can drop back to E7
eliminating the pin on the Knight E7 is
a perfectly nice solid Square for the
bishop and let's play Knight C6 and
develop our Knight remember that after
white plays B4 that pawn on B4 can later
be used as a Target we could chisel away
at White's Queen Side by playing A5 but
only after White's Pawn has appeared on
before that is a super typical way of
attacking Pawn chains you can attack the
base of the pawn chain which is the
traditional method that's like removing
the bottom Jenga out of the entire
structure but you can also attack the
tip of the pawn chain and sometimes that
has a pretty strong effect as well okay
so let's play Knight C6 we also could
have castled here I think both moves are
entirely acceptable
there are many ways of developing in
such a position there isn't always one
correct move
okay Knight F4
this gives us a perfect opportunity to
play a move that we were thinking of
playing a little bit earlier what am I
talking about
first thing that I see when I when
Knight F4 is on the board is that this
bishop on G5 has been fully deprived of
squares
so what does that tell us well it tells
us that the time has come for us to play
H6 now it forces white to trade the
bishop for the night allowing Our Queen
to move into an incredibly active spot
on F6 and in general white has traded
one of uh their main pieces uh in this
position the dark Squad Bishop is is
like the pride of the position the
trumpowski now we've got a great
position Queen is on F6 attacking B2
it's also pressuring F2
and already black has an advantage
Knight H5
okay our opponents are coming to one
moveitis I think
or maybe not let's think
actually not not a not a terrible move
by any means but I think we can get away
with taking the pawn on B2
and I think a lot of people who are
newer to chess are sort of automatically
afraid of taking that pawn on B2 because
you've been told the horror stories
about how the queen always gets trapped
when it takes that pawn anytime you're
thinking about taking a pawn in your
opponent's territory with your queen you
have to calculate concretely what
happens after Queen takes B2 well
White's probably going to go Rook B1
and there we just need to realize that
the queen is defending this important
Pawn on G7 we definitely don't want to
give that pawn away with check so after
Queen takes B2 Rook B1
we should move the queen along the same
diagonal well what squares are available
on that diagonal well first of all we
can move the queen back to C3
but then the Rook can pursue us with
Rook B3
so Queen C3 is not the best move the
best move after Queen B2 Rook B1 is to
drop the queen back to E5
and you might say well the queen in the
center is very vulnerable white could
just attack the queen with F4 but
pushing upon weakens other pawns F4
gives up E3 with check
and if after Queen takes B2 Rook B1
Queen E5 white tries to chase the queen
with the Knight then that severs the
connection between the White Queen and
the Knight on H5 allowing us to take on
H5 okay so simple calculation we can
safely take on B2 no problem at all
now I should point out
that after Rook B1 even if E5 for
whatever reason would have been
inaccessible to our Queen let's assume
that the pawn was on F4
there is nothing terribly wrong with
taking the pawn on A3 it's not like if
white takes on G7 the game ends right
you should never just assume that just
because your King has to make a move in
the opening that somehow you're already
on the cusp of getting mated we would
slide our King to f8 and the King line
f8 while not ideal would still be
decently placed
of course it's not desirable but it
wouldn't be the end of the world either
all right so our opponent is thinking
Rook B1 is a very tempting move
but I just don't see too many other
options for our opponent if if they
develop the bishop to D3 we can respond
by playing G6 solving the problem of the
Pawn on G7 and chasing the Knight away
from H5
so we're up upon here
we're up Upon Our pieces are nicely
developed at some point we should
probably get this light skirt Bishop out
maybe put it on D7 just to connect the
Rooks but that's not urgent at all
yf8 wouldn't it be safer on e77 oh
you're asking about the king no I think
D7 would be a bad spot for the king
because that walks right into the X-ray
along the D file it also permanently
like fully blocks the bishop on D7
and the King on E7 no I think that the
further along the king is the less safe
it is right if it's on the seventh rank
there's all sorts of checks like Knight
F5 you know I think the King on f8 is
you know relatively speaking the safest
Square because it's still surrounded by
the spawn cover
yeah our opponent finally taking his
time Bishop E2 okay
well that's a reasonable move
and uh we have multiple ways to deal
with the pawn on G7 I pointed out the
move G6 which is sort of the forcing
option but some of you also indicated
that we can simply Castle
and
now that I'm looking at this a little
bit more deeply I really like the idea
of castling here because it basically
kills two birds with one stone right we
continue our development and
simultaneously
we protect the pawn on G7 now if I were
playing white here I would seriously
contemplate the move G4 in this position
trying to create counter play on the
king side using the fact that white has
not castled yet
and that is part of a very important
Trope to remember which is the situation
in which one side has castled and the
other side has not
people often assume that the side that
has castled stands to benefit from that
but that's not always the case sometimes
The Rook on H1 can be used to benefit
the side that hasn't castled yet if you
can open up the H file quickly and
there's a great book called The Art of
attack in chess
by vukovic it's an old book from the 30s
there's a good chessable version of it
it has a whole chapter on uh the
situation in which
you know one king remains in the center
and the other king castles early
movinesh asks why did we not take on A3
it is it would have been possible to
take on A3 that would not have been a
terrible move
first of all it would have created a lot
of awkwardness with the queen and the
bishop I would be afraid of losing the
bishop
but more uh more more concretely after
Bishop takes A3 we would have allowed
Knight takes G7 check
deflecting the queen right Queen takes
G7 Rook takes a three and I didn't want
to allow any damage of my kingside Pawn
stroker we're trying to play as solidly
as possible
but now we absolutely could take on A3
not just could take on A3 I think we
will take on A3 because there's no
reason not to that's a pawn
and we have
we have earned the right to take that
pawn because we've solved the immediate
problems of our position we've castled
our Center is
uh nice and safe and secure so
you know don't be under the impression
that you know I always like to caution
you against taking material but that
doesn't mean you don't take stuff if
it's literally free
just Bishop takes A3 now we're up two
Pawns
and to remember the curve of diminishing
returns when you're up one Pawn taking
that second one is incredibly meaningful
when you're up two pawns taking the
third one is already far less meaningful
E4 that's a great move by our opponent
but it doesn't actually do anything it
doesn't threaten anything
because D5 is defended by this Pawn on
E6 moreover if white were to take on D5
and we were to recapture our light
squared Bishop would be opened up so we
actually kind of want white to take on
e4 so there's many ways to treat this to
play this position a lot of you of
course are tempted by the move Knight
before or Knight D4
um let me explain why I don't like
either of these moves let's take as a
sample to move Knight before
White Castles kingside and then you can
say well there's a third Pawn on C2 but
that's where the the line has been
crossed from calculated greed to Too
Much greed Knight takes C2 look at how
all of our pieces are going to be
clustered on the queen side after Rogue
B1 Our Queen is virtually overextended
we could end up losing a minor piece
there we also might probably wouldn't
but there's it involves a lot of
calculation and there is no need we're
already up two pawns we can make a much
safer move
so what seems to be a safe move that
improves our position well
when I look at this I don't like the
placement of the bishop right we took
the pawn on A3 but that Bishop is in a
very awkward spot it's also keeping the
queen tied down to the queen side so it
makes sense to move that Bishop away now
where should we move it well we have
several good squares we can move it back
to C5 to pressure the F2 Pawn
we can move it back to B4 to create the
pin against the Knight on D2 which I
know a lot of people are tempted by but
after Bishop E4 remember that that pin
is temporary Bishop B4 white can castle
kingside and then that Bishop looks a
little bit dumb I actually like the move
Bishop D6
which to some people might be the least
appealing of the squares but to me is
the most appealing because this pressure
is actually meaningful Bishop takes G3
is a serious positional threat because
it completely ruins White's kingside
Pawn structure
so my two preferred moves would have
been Bishop C5 or Bishop D6 I think both
of them
uh are are perfectly sufficient and
probably about equivalent
but I like Bishop D6 Rook B1 okay
chasing the queen out of B2 great thing
that we moved our Bishop away from A3
where should we move our Queen well
again we should try to find a square
that is both active but also out of the
way of the other pieces
um what Square comes to mind well Queen
C3 is possible but the reason I wouldn't
want to play Queen C3 is probably
because white has the move Rook B3
chasing the queen away again
um I like the look of Queen F6
Queen F6 does run into Knight H5 though
but then we can tuck Our Queen back to
E7
that seems to be a very good option
Queen F6 and the Knight H5 Queen E7
um what else is on the menu we can drop
our Queen back to D4
I actually ooh that square I like the
most yeah let's play Queen D4 you know
why because the queen is actually very
difficult to attack on this square if
you think about it white is no good way
to attack the queen if the Knight moves
away from D2 that opens up the
possibility of a queen trade okay Ed we
obviously play D but the second reason I
really like this move is that it
prevents castles that blunders a knight
it prevents castles and our opponent
immediately resigns because if y would
have castled here then Bishop takes G3
uh wins the piece because of the pin on
the F2 Pawn again we see the the sort of
same type of narrative in all of these
games which is that when we put a lot of
pressure in the opening in early middle
game people often just sort of collapse
but White's position was of course
already losing
all right another relatively
straightforward game this one a little
bit more meat on the bone
let's take a quick look
so
I won't at this point in the speed run
delve too deeply into the theory
even though that is the emphasis of this
speedrun but instead I'm going to focus
on general concepts so in this position
as I said there are many good moves
I'll let you do some investigation on
your own I really like the move D5 this
is often not talked about uh enough
because the two main moves are Knight E4
and E6 but D5 is a really really good
move and then usually white takes on F6
because that's the whole point of Bishop
G5 and here I really like the line G
takes F6 which leads to this very gritty
interesting Pawn structure black has the
bishop pair which I love and I just like
this structure in general
so I don't remember exactly how the
theory goes here I think white is
supposed to play E3
and then much like in the game you have
the structure which calls forth the move
C5
and if white takes on C5 then black is
in no immediate hurry to win this Pawn
back I think the main line is well we
try to win the pawn back with E6
and I don't think white is supposed to
cling to the pawn of B4
I drew says I have no idea what's going
on um if you're lost then you can ask
questions but I'm trying to be as clear
as possible
so after B4 how is black supposed to
deal with this particular Pawn chain
remember that I said there's two options
you can attack the base of the pawn
chain but if possible that's what you
should do you can attack the tip you can
attack the base attacking the base is
generally the more successful uh
successful strategy so here you should
play A5
which leads to a very classic scenario
black white cannot play A3
because the Rook on A1 is undefended
notice that if the Knight had been
developed already to D2 A3 would have
been possible so everything comes down
to concrete details here of course white
can play C3 and defend from the other
side but now you can play a b c b and
you can play the move B6 which is a sort
of traditional way of attacking the
ponchi now you have softened it up and
now you go after the tip of the pawn
chain
because if CB you take on B4 and then
take on B6 with a tremendous position
but you can also play simply Knight C6
exploiting the fact that A3 runs into
Knight takes before the same principle
with the Rook being undefended so we've
had this type of scenario in speed runs
before this is like super common
occurrence in all of these D4 openings
the situation in which one side has
grabbed the pawn on C5 or you could
imagine the same thing with colors
reversed if black takes the pawn on C4
and understanding how those structures
work is integral if you want to play
this successfully for either side
in any case D5 is a good move we played
Knight E4 white plays H4
and we decided to keep it simple with
the move D5
so there's a bunch of lines and I know
Levy's course Levy recommends this in
his course
um
there's a there's a bunch of lines where
white actually pushes the pawn to G6
here
so for example black can try the move
e75.
and I don't remember exactly where white
plays G6 it might be here
but the point of G6 again is that you
cannot take with the h-bond you drop the
rook and if you have to take with the F
Pawn then notice how much you've damaged
your king side and white has long-term
pressure against the H7 Pawn so I
actually don't love this type of
position for black
we decided to
play D5 and really keep it simple by
playing Knight F6
white is slightly better here I don't
dispute that white is definitely
slightly better here but Black's
position is tremendously solid so we
play E6 in order to prepare C5 and
already I think 92 is a step in the
wrong direction it's just too passive
it's not a big mistake but I don't
understand why our opponent didn't just
develop either Knight to F3 and then we
would have played C5 and white can play
this kind of like a London uh with with
C3 and then bringing the light squared
Bishop to D3 white is a good position
white is a good position so 92 is a
little bit passive
D take C5 also a little bit passive at
this point I already think black is
better
yielding the center like this is not a
good idea white should play C3 if he
wants to be solid if white wants to be
ambitious white can consider counter
striking in the center with the move C4
creating this sort of Pawn Cube
um
so DC just yields yields control of the
center which is a bad thing
now our opponent plays A3 and notice
here that we don't fear the move before
because it's absolutely not dangerous it
sends our Bishop uh to a square that it
wants to go to anyway Bishop E7
uh no this is not a king's Indian this
is a trumpowski
okay maybe white should have played B4
and then C4
but here we would just ignore by
castling and this is exactly where white
is burned for pushing H4 so early whites
King has no Safe Haven and with the
center getting opened it gets really
really dangerous for white really
quickly
yeah you just ignore and notice how
solid how solid black structure is this
is the benefit of a healthy Pond
structure you can just continue
developing your pieces you don't have to
constantly React to what your opponent
is doing if B5 then you can play 95
threatening Checkmate in one move
all right so
I think the key takeaway from this part
of the game if you're like a newer
player is that well first is that you
should never just like automatically
always try to prevent every one of your
opponent's ideas prophylaxis is a very
important concept but it should be used
in response to actually dangerous ideas
so the first order of business is to
actually ask yourself is this worth
preventing very often your opponent's
idea actually helps you rather than your
opponent
hopefully that makes sense so Knight C6
our opponent plays Knight F4 another
mistake which allows us to get this
bishop on G5 and now we have the bishop
pair a beautiful queen on F6 and really
the decisive mistake was to blunder the
spawn on B2 after Queen takes B2 white
is probably already lost
um okay what should I do here probably
white should play the unglamorous but
necessary move C3 to blunt the queen and
protect B2
and then we would have probably castled
kingside and white would have gotten uh
his Bishop out to E2 or whatever
and here a good plan for black is to
prepare the move E5 now why is E5
impossible because of blunders D5 so who
can tell me a good way to prepare E5
what is the most harmonious way of
preparing E5
very good it's Rook da Rook d8 is sort
of the classic right you put the Rook
behind the pawn and the reason that you
want to do that because to some people
it might seem well but aren't we putting
the Rook on a closed file yeah but
you're using the Rook as a support you
can think of the pawn as an extension of
The Rook also later in the game
you might play the move d4 and that's
exactly where you want your Rook on d8
should the D file open you've already
positioned your Rook preemptively on the
best possible Square
so Rook d8 here would be great
what's interesting is that the engine is
suggesting the move G4 which might be
White's best chance in response to
Castle kingside
uh it might be just to run this Pawn
down to G5 and try to open up
the um
the age file
so
a good example of a situation in which
the side that delays castling benefits
is the fishing pole variation of the re
Lopez right in the fishing pole
variation which
um of the exchange re Lopez
black plays this move Bishop G4 and
responds to H3 with H5 and this will be
kind of mind-boggling if this is the
first time that you see this line
chances are most of you have seen this
before even if you don't play the real
Lopez uh H5 baits white into capturing
this bishop after H takes G4 white is
already lost because the open H file
almost immediately leads to Checkmate
especially if the knight from F3 moves
away Queen H4 is forced mate white
cannot prevent the main on H1 or H2 F3
you play G3 to cover the F2 square and
then you made on H1 so this is like a
very basic example but the Takeaway on a
more abstract level is that just because
one castling is not always a race right
you want to be careful about castling
into an attack
um if your opponent is still on castled
and has the means to start attacking
your king side right you want to be
careful about that so in any case back
we go to the game Queen takes B2 we win
the pawn
Bishop E2 we Castle then we take another
Pawn because why not that pawn is
totally free
uh and then we drop our Bishop back to
D6 a nice solid Square pressuring that
energy three
then we move our Queen to the center the
center isn't always a vulnerable spot
for the queen here it's not vulnerable
because if white moves the Knight on F3
then of course we will trade queens and
then we can respond by winning another
pawn bishop takes G3 and de or you can
throw in a nice little check on before
and just run this Apon up the board
actually ignoring the thread on D5 and
just play A5 here
yeah big deal white wins one of the
pawns but this Pawn is just gonna reach
A1 uh in the blink of an eye
and then you're gonna put the bishop on
C3 at the right moment to cover the A1
Square
so a simple game and of course our
opponent collapsed EDD Knight of five
Bishop five is a free piece the game is
over
so 17 moves key takeaways in the
trumpowski for now you can just remember
the move 94 and I'm sure we will get a
chance
uh to to to talk about more Theory later
we'll face this again after Bishop F4 if
you've watched my Blitz Games you know
that I'm a bear I'm very partial to the
move Knight C6 which is a super rare
sideline but it's a super tricky line
it's easy to learn and it's what I'm
going to recommend to you uh once we hit
the trumpowski again for now H4 you can
keep it simple by dropping your knight
back to F6
then in positions symmetrical Queen Pawn
positions you often want to push the C
Pawn rather than the e-pawn to contest
to the center
um if Bishop H4 then the move is
actually G5 continuing to chase the
bishop
and if the bishop drops back to G3 after
H5 black is already better because
there's this massive threat of trapping
the bishop with H4 this is an idea worth
remembering now you might say well big
deal what's the big deal white just goes
H3 but the moment white pushes the H
Pawn now you take on G3 forcing this
disgusting move and White's entire King
side has been ruined very typical idea
across many different types of openings
one example that comes to mind in the
jababa London uh there is a line where
white plays E3 6 Knight F3 bishop d695
and if black plays a nonchalant move
such as whatever A6 then after G4 black
is already in trouble same Concepts
Bishop G6 H4 and you're like is this hey
am I really going to lose the bishop
here well there's no way to defend
against H5 other than pushing your own H
Pawn and if you do that and white can
take on G6 ruining your entire King side
and creating weaknesses right so just
remember this idea anytime you have a
bishop on F5 or F4
but again we will discuss the theory in
more granular detail uh in a couple
hundred points the next time we Face the
trumpowski all right another simple game
but hopefully you enjoyed it thanks
again everybody for the support thanks
for the support on YouTube we're close
to 300K Subs so each sub counts thanks
for hanging out see you tomorrow